This
is the Cal N.E.H. American English dialect recordings
collection produced with funding from the National Endowment for the Humanities and the Center for
Applied Linguistics. This is tape number fifty
six side a.
Long
course.
Well
since
the tracks happened twelve helps me out on plan
and. I think.
Yes. Nine hundred fifty two.
Over to the city. Actually I was born a home away
from
the
police
department all
over
yes I
was in Shiprock I was a
policeman
to the bank.
There's a big difference in the
language different
to different attitudes
different or more
of the backstage where I'm from
some. My the people living today
are still there behind maybe twenty years or
so if you go to when the rockets more into the
city it's minimal. And
sure people are.
And
they don't like to progress the kind of
competitive the people that I'll show you
more contact with people there or
in nature. But you don't get to know people there
or the good people you don't get a chance to meet.
That's from my point of view
these areas are because we would
promote my own
culture.
Strangely.
I
was
raised
my father is not educated. My mom
is mine probably.
That's how he related to traditional. Israel is very
strict morals and
ethics most came
from I have a love interest.
And I have one
brother. We're both long course.
My father's father was a police at that time
the only one. And he moves around with he
was in the
lead in this came to the family.
Most
weeks.
Not really well it's you know once you get the hang of it it's
flexible
both
sides but if
you look at things how people just
back into how you were taught me. It's kind of the weird.
You know how people I come here. Specially the young to
fight some
strange things.
So to the people really they really don't care.
This image of people.
I don't
know there are no two
to have freedom and what we have
here at the court is the say for example which is. I
live with your forces. And how those people
are over there. And then you come back and
you look at these people to the
critical situations of how life
is how American
society
makes except
sometimes.
In general I think it's
because
I'm giving an example.
We got to the little
boy we follow he had a hole.
We took him down to the public
service and they told us
that he's too young he's connected
with them to do some repairs.
So we just fly like he complained about a plane you
know we took him down there
constantly ten years old or something.
So we call up to around for
some special called up to Salt Lake City. So
we took
him took him up to the pub
to get upset because you know he told us that should have been done a long time ago.
So we made plans with
it
I don't know how long he had
for several
years.
On top of it. You know he did it in one day with
the actually four hour
job of a minute of the
people discover them just looking at a story to tell
you but it did a good job and he told
us we came back because you can stay with it or to come home come back within two weeks
so we came back down and we didn't even try to talk to the doctor saying
we can't take just people. Rep enough
if we want to do it himself and these people keep the people down you went through.
To
Canterbury and to the city.
I'm a doctor.
A lot of these were only a kind of frustrating but then again you know what can we
do in society learn out of the country as being the minority
sometimes with the punches. We do.
But just imagine how many other people
or the Indians don't get the care that they need.
I think that we have look at as they look
at. Kind of blaming the Indian
for not
paying for these
medical
houses
certain angle people or somebody else on the front look it's
our fault that. We don't pay for his medical expenses.
It's not the people there
or that
are can't afford to go to these public services and I
think somehow or other somehow they get to get the repercussion.
These emotional
feelings
the striker for example a little boy playing with a new car a
new toy and somebody who can pay for somebody with a needle.
We're putting out there like you really are straight.
But the way I look at it. I think a lot of these people that really needs medical assistance
don't have no place else to go is the victim of these people that
are getting free medical let him have the
best doctor we are looking at.
We
investigated some
accidents a lot of them
won and the appropriately we should have
been a victim
of this is this is this is
true in the Get involved in the accident.
Taking to heart clinics.
It takes ages for them to get through
the
pain and nobody to talk to have to be called and he the prompter takes his
time coming up maybe two hours
waiting for that it's an
angle you know a plane comes
in from Gallup
Farmington to the
specialize to some of these.
And I've seen a lot of cases. If they had
proper services.
You know a lot of these are.
Spinal
head
injury.
And
that's
somebody
not related you really don't care
for them
and
is very slow especially
when we go up to the first one of the
screen and they come in and it's coming it takes ages
to secure the
scene and all of the time but we just don't have the material to secured the
person
because like a family we didn't
get proper first the supplies. We don't
have you
know the best thing we do stabilize it.
And finally we kind of improve for a while because kind of
improving right now because right now we can call Flagstaff helicopter.
And. I think it's
just the animosity
on the plane you
know.
Probably
all related.
We
did.
used
to
only
problem
but I think the only problem that I complain
about
why people suffer because
somebody doesn't take the time to
get
what I think. I think a lot of
the problems
with
the people that
could get better treatment without
get somebody in there. Or at least the people that it's
really not
that they should be held
responsible because they're getting free medical. I
think. And
this was
a.
My
family.
Well we don't take we don't like I said to be honest we don't take we used to one or
more we don't take my family or my kids
to public health service on the
reservation.
Well
I
was raised with love to see that things go
away when you're sick you know you don't you don't.
We never used to stay in bed or in stores when we have a sore throat or something like
that and my father's philosophy was get up there and tough it
out and that's the way I look at it
but sometimes if you have kids
different.
Well we do it we take them to
two to landing or.
Checked
and then they recommend from there we go.
I
guess
it
depends on. What you know all the people
are human is aware of the symptoms of what it
is what might be like like a heart attack or something. People should be
made aware of the symptoms.
And
I think that the only way people kind of scare them a little too. If somebody is really having the
kind of symptoms if whoever is taking care of the older couple or poor
little child you know depends on the front and how what they know
well and then they should respond to to a hospital
and maybe with that in mind.
I
think in most areas under reservation most of the young kids
left lead leader of the grandmothers
grandfathers or their parents.
There is not a comfortable with the way they
are with the type of traditional It is for you know. Werman
home because they're more
I think they're better are they feel better in a modern society where there's
music and dancing in movies in
the north are they trying to move away from these areas in the
in town
somewhere lose the old people behind
and these old people don't really know much
about hell or these certain symptoms that they
might be having some kind of young
and then again my
father they don't believe in hospitals.
Doing what they do really don't want to hospital at same time I guess it's just the kind of treatment that
they get from the hospital that they don't want to go.
My father you can't take him and.
My father was an ET was involved in an accident into the city one time brother in
law and him were driving down a road and discarded robot in front of them and they had had a fight.
Trip brought it
on and he fell for him hit his head on the
dash and they took him to the to the hospital to the city in
the wrong. So gifted took him out to come back and I was I was
overseas than this is what I hear he took him back he stood over there for the week and
he keeps complaining by here. Problems and they took him to the hospital. To the
city and there was nothing at all
to prove his
Lake's wasn't responding as he should as it should. So he complained he talked to
my brother who was sitting and he brought him to Flagstaff and they took X. rays
and found they had a concussion and were
hit and blood was accumulating in there and was pushing against raining
that was causing the dizzy and coordination was impaired.
So this wound on the Phoenix hospital where he had a surgery.
And they could clean all the blood out of there and it's been about three months
done and then
he came back. Now he's pretty
healthy and the you ask him you know if he's sick or
something you want to stop by go to the city hospital he will want
to hear you. Yeah because
he's been treated
better.
He
didn't need well what happened everybody was he was bouncing he was down there.
He had my. My grandfather and his father. You know they
have we have certain prayers. How man was made and
how the
person or. Supposedly
rejuvenate
demoralise there's a thing called the blessing we call
the
psychological pick
another go at.
And my grandfather went down there and you know when he was in the
hospital and he conducted the prayer for him.
My father's
very determined person stubborn sometimes
but I respect him
because he never with
a never hit me or anything you chewed me out you
know but I respected him and he had
NEVER have I seen him
drunk or Never have I seen him
smoking and staying with my mom.
And
that's what he told me I believe and
what he believed firmly that.
I guess when he does a person on me or something really weird. Because when
I was leaving.
We climb the mountain here. San Francisco pick almost to the top.
And I'm going overseas. And I came
back to the States. I mean.
When
I came there.
I
don't think as compared
to
well
I think what we really need on the reservation is
more education for the elderly.
There are some people there and still manage
their sterling.
Half of one or two at home. To keep the tradition
going and that's the last thing. There's some kids up there
that don't want to go to school they don't want the parents want to go
to
school from there are learning. They're still learning
like the singing
because it's still there. But you can't really
look you know in
town where these
are
going.
They
don't have
any I don't.
They don't know me you know I really I went to school.
I know I'm really fine and the really nice.
Like the family of
mother brother and sister fighting or
or brother fighting the father. And the nude
exist
in until
like
me can I go to school you go to school and then go home you know just like that and I
was
never really involved in other it's just the
way I was raised. So if you're raised that way you're
more disciplined I
think a lot of things don't bother you lot of things
don't bother me when you know somebody does because I don't
take it as an
attack or I don't take it as a degrading type of remark. When somebody
says you know I'm an idiot or something
that another person's philosophy for
people either opinion right. And I just take it as it is because my father
said you are
or with
somebody
don't take what they say personally don't let him. Don't let other people come into
you keep him out because that's where they belong
in the attitude and I guess
lot of them live in a store up there.
They have the attitude. I wish to go to school for the learn
more I My father wanted me to to
learn some of his songs. But.
I probably would have the only thing the family and. Support gotta
get some money somewhere to support it maybe later on. He's a
read anyway so he can wait.
Well
I
won't do it as for profit or for
other other
people or philosophy or a prophecy that
runs our prayers or things are all to cheer
you all gone. In a very existence. You
know my father was at
least one of us my brother my other brother in the cell to carry
on what it's supposed to be so people can
exist.
Let's reset the whole custom and religion is gone.
That's
twenty.